[Music]
Ariel winter beat the heat over the
weekend turning heads in this cutout
mini dress at the premiere of her new
movie Smurfs The Lost village the Meghan
Trainor's song on their soundtrack is
I'm a lady what's your favorite quality
in a lady so where does Ariel get her
confidence really she's an amazing
person she always taught me like feel
good about yourself no matter if you're
in your pajamas at the grocery store if
you're in a ball gown at a premiere how
much longer do you think Modern Family's
gonna go for him what are you looking
forward to doing that some grown-up
stuff net yes definitely that's what I'm
looking for right now is you know I'm 19
I want to push forward in my adult
career but here a man who's gonna be
harder being in the public eye and being
on such a popular show but also growing
up in front of the cameras right in
front of the camera it's hard to grow go
through your you know I'm a kid to have
an adult fade it's kind of weird so it's
definitely been kind of hard
[Music]